[Music]
chef Sarah Gruenberg got an early start
on her culinary career growing up in
Houston she loved to cook and bake and
took over the kitchen when her mom
traveled for work after culinary school
she cut her teeth at legendary
restaurants like Brennan's of Houston
and spiaggia in Chicago and Chicago is
where she opened her own monteverde last
year it was named one of food & Wine's
restaurants of the year and just last
month another incredible honor Gruenberg
won to the 2017 James Beard Award as
Best Chef Great Lakes chef Sarah Gruber
welcome to the dish thank you
congratulations on the James Beard Award
how did that feel it was incredible it
was such an honor I was it was the first
time I was nominated so I really didn't
prepare a speech I thought I'm doing a
day job you like and so I was like um I
just went up there and I was like I
can't believe this happened this is real
like so it was it was a lot of fun and I
wish I could relive that memory again it
was incredible graduations on it we just
had the legendary Tony Montanaro Montu
on oh sorry here he was one of your
mentors in Chicago he was a huge mentor
for me taught me that the most important
ingredient is the one you leave out of
Italian cuisine and sent me on my first
trip to Italy thanks ed of all but I
understand that you actually opened your
first restaurant in fourth grade in
effect I did yes it was called flavors
of the world and it was a restaurant
just about all different kinds of
cuisine and actually employed mock
employed my friends in school and it was
under the bleachers and it was grass and
flowers we had money and coupons and
menus and A's it was a lot of fun well
this is one specific cuisine that we're
talking about here what do we have yes
so Monteverde really celebrates pasta
when you walk into the restaurant you
celebrated don't eat do you see pasta
being made behind the bar in our pasta
feed show this is a yolk at T which is
tossed with pesto and ricotta and pine
nuts really simple but one of those
dishes that takes you back and you're
like I really love this yes I really
love then celebrating spring roasted
asparagus I like to put them right on
the pan and dry roast them so they get a
nice caramelized char color
fried eggs manchego fonduta and then it
just very close to my heart
redfish I grew up fishing with my family
and my uncle down in Texas and the bays
we go Wade fishing we actually walk out
and stand in the water and fish for
redfish so redfish acqua Pazza and then
the great green mountain salad this is a
salad after myoma was a famous salad she
made and it just it just celebrates
everything you like about a salad great
picado great it is it is it's like so
you said you said as you said you grew
up in Houston but what took you to
Chicago ultimately took me to Chicago is
I really wanted to branch out I had
really done a great job at Brennan's I
moved up the ranks I was the first
sous-chef at 22 years old and I worked
under Chris Shepherd who taught me to go
in the cooler and let the vegetables
speak to me to work on specials did the
vegetables speak to you they did they
did what daddy say they said use me you
want beets in this dish which was hard
as a young chef like an ingredient like
beets yeah and I really loved Houston
but I wanted to branch out and uh so I
flew to Chicago and stodg at a few
restaurants and met Missy Robbins and
Izzy Robin great so Robin yes I got it
yes and she gave me my first shot and I
moved to Chicago and moved there in Oh 5
August about 5 and worked at spiaggia
for 8 years I worked my way through out
the kitchen and how'd it how terrifying
was it to open your first place on your
own
you're young you're all woman these are
you know these are these are challenges
in the restaurant world they are I guess
the biggest challenge for me was hoping
that people would love the concept
hoping that it would shine through you
know you work so hard on what is what is
your restaurant concept gonna be yeah
and I knew celebrating pasta was an area
that I loved that I was passionate about
and also that I think Chicago in the
u.s. really loves pasta every culture
does right but you come close to a
booming restaurant town with a lot of
competition how scary was that leap I
don't know I think I just kind of went
for it you know you if you're scared I
think fear is what
we can hold you back so I really tried
to be strong and just say alright I'm
going to do it day by day
and I have a great business partner Meg
saws who we were actually line cooks at
spiaggia together we met no.5 everything
comes everything everything does we have
met our partners there might be on say
and her husband we all cooked together
and we open Monteverde so it's just it's
a and your family friend affair best
chef Great Lakes region no small feat
chef Gruenberg as I asked you to sign
this dish I'll also ask you the question
of questions which is if you could share
this this bounty with any person past or
present who would it be well I think
giving my grandparents who are still
doing grade 90 and 87 who taught me a
lot and my uncle who's longer with us
but he taught me a lot about cooking and
being a good Texas woman so it sound
like you've done him proud yes being
gradually everything chef Sarah Grunberg
thank you and for more on Sarah
greenberg and the dish head to our
website at CBS this morning calm